تعرض مقاطعة لوس أنجلوس
مكافأة قدرها 250 ألف دولار لمن يدلي
بمعلومات تتعلق بإطلاق النار على
نائب الشريف رايان كلينكنبرومر، حيث
تم إطلاق النار عليه وقُتل داخل
سيارة الدورية الخاصة به يوم السبت، ويقول المسؤولون إنهم
يعتقدون أنه من المحتمل أن يكون مستهدفًا
ونصب كمينًا للدكتور ميلر بيرنال.
يتابع كل هذا من لا، لقد كان
يرتدي زيه العسكري وكان داخل
سيارة الدورية الخاصة به وتعتقد السلطات أن
هذا قد يكون
استهدافًا متعمدًا له، ماذا نعرف هذا
الصباح، نعم، يقول بوبي الشريف
أنه ربما كان ذلك لمجرد أنه كان
يرتدي  زيه الرسمي والآن
يتم استخدام جميع الموارد المتاحة
للعثور على الشخص أو الأشخاص المسؤولين
عن هذا، يتعهد الشريف بالعثور على
من فعل هذا، أريد مراجعة
الجدول الزمني لما حدث هنا،
لقد ذكرت أنه كان في سيارة دورية مميزة
كان يرتدي الزي الرسمي أثناء الخدمة، وكان
يغادر المحطة للتو في
ليلة السبت حوالي الساعة 6 مساءً في بالمديل التي
تبعد حوالي 60 ميلاً شمال لوس أنجلوس،
وتوقف عند إشارة حمراء، وهناك مقطع فيديو
حصلت عليه شبكة CNN يُظهر سيارة تسير
بجوار دوريته  سيارة ثم تسرع
مبتعدة الآن ما تقول السلطات إنها
سيارة مثيرة للاهتمام هي سيارة تويوتا كورولا باللون الرمادي الداكن موديل 2006 إلى 2012
ويطلبون مقاطع فيديو للحصول على معلومات لأي
شخص لإلقاء نظرة على هذا لأنهم
يقولون إنها قد تكون قطعة اللغز المفقودة
إنهم يريدون معلومات من
الجمهور وقد عرضوا
مكافأة قدرها 250 ألف دولار